please welcome CEO of worldwide consumer
at Amazon
Jeff Wilkie thank you
welcome to rebars whoo did you did you
enjoy the presentations last night
all right great I thought they were
terrific well I'm thrilled that each of
you is here this week we invited you
because each of you has significant
contributions to make to the
conversation on AI nml whether you're an
astronaut
AI scientist or a CEO and by the way I
looked through some of the titles my
favorite one was CEO and chief geek you
know who you are
somewhere out there some of us have been
working on AI for decades but we're only
in the beginning stages of truly
understanding the potential for this
technology technology to change our
lives and to help us work on some of the
most important and urgent problems that
humanity faces at Amazon we know were
one of just many voices working on this
problem so remar is is an opportunity
for us to come together to share and to
learn from each other let me take a
minute to introduce myself I'm one of
the other Geoff's
at Amazon more officially I'm CEO of the
worldwide consumer business this
includes prime robotics fulfillment
Amazon business Amazon go whole foods
prime air and of course amazon.com
amazon germany amazon japan and more all
together these groups account for more
than 600,000 Amazonians we're kindred
spirits Amazon is a company founded by
computer scientists and incredible
coders and increasingly were propelled
forward by pioneering work of AI
scientists over the next 60 minutes
you're gonna get a look at how AI is
shaped Amazon you'll see how AI guides
our shopping experiences and accelerates
how quickly we can get packages to
customers you'll get the latest intel on
alexa and our voice recognition efforts
and along the way you'll see some really
cool demos of new and upcoming products
and you'll get a glimpse into our future
amazon amazon has been a technology
company from the start it helps that our
founder was a computer scientist I grew
up as a programmer that's me this is my
tum ik Sinclair 1000 computer anybody in
the room have a Timex Sinclair 1000 yeah
alright so if you had one you know it
had my version a 2k of memory it was not
useful for writing machine learning
algorithms by the way I look at this
picture and I'm guessing that Jeff
already was connected to some massive
storage in the cloud and if you had one
of these I had to use the tape recorder
my dad's tape recorder in order to save
data and it wasn't very much data the
best thing I did with this in about 1900
bytes
I wrote a video poker machine after
visiting Vegas with my grandparents and
it hadn't helped me at all this week
unfortunately when I first showed up at
Amazon in 1999 I let our global
operations team I started to ask
questions about how we decided where to
place inventory and which warehouses
fulfillment centers to assign orders to
it was especially important to get this
right during our holiday season when
capacity is so constrained for us we
didn't have much in the way of
operations research or formal applied
math teams at the time we were relying
primarily on skip let me explain skip
briefly skip is not an algorithm skip is
a dude
skip Brodhead great guy skip had a model
of the whole operation in his head
and when you had to rebalance the work
or solve a problem you'd walk into his
office you'd explain the situation and
he couldn't do it exactly where we
needed to go he would figure out what we
had to change what knobs to turn and he
was usually right but after my first
holiday I was pretty convinced that skip
was not gonna scale so in 2000 we set up
an Operations research team to begin to
work on improving the algorithms that
ran our operations we joked that we were
working on an auto skip Oh our was the
right field of applied math to figure
out how to minimize the cost of
inventory and the cost of delivering
orders from our supply chain and
fulfillment networks but even a know
argh
could only take us so far we were on
path to 200 fulfillment centers 20
inbound crossed docks 100 sort centers
on a path to deploying more than 200,000
robots and simultaneously creating more
than 300,000 jobs in our fulfillment
centers our use of automation and
robotics by reducing the need for our
associates to walk from point to point
or to push heavy loads of packages
improves the safety and the productivity
of those jobs and it lets us pay higher
wages a similar approach has led to some
great improvements in the customer
experience on amazon.com let me explain
what I mean by looking at the evolution
of product discovery product discovery
was heavily based on human curation and
best sellers when we started customers
would browse selection in a physical
store or online that a merchandiser
chose based on intuition data and trends
but this method was inherently biased
toward the merchandisers own preferences
it failed to capture some niche
interests like mushroom picking or board
games
the very first recommendation engine
that we built using collaborative
filtering was considered revolutionary
20 years ago it was an early version of
a machine learning algorithm
that recommendation engine helps
customers discover related items like a
camera bag
or the lens for a camera that a customer
had just purchased it's still on the
site and it's still a huge help for
customers when we later combine
collaborative filtering with heuristics
to make recommendations we were able to
give customers personalized
recommendations rather than just showing
them popular items fast forward a few
years and in the exponential growth of
computing power provided by Amazon Web
Services plus the improvement of
sophisticated machine learning
algorithms and we start to get
dramatically better results on the order
of two times better than a typical
algorithmic improvement that's a once in
a decade leap that helps us to
personalize our content and recommend
goods that a customer would like to buy
and movies that a customer's more likely
to watch let me explain how we achieved
these goals and it wasn't a
straight-line to realize the
improvements in 2012 we wanted to update
our product recommendation algorithm to
improve personalization for customers we
started from state-of-the-art graph
clustering techniques then we shifted
our approach under the hypothesis that
deep learning methods would outperform
matrix completion methods because we
could take advantage of nonlinearities
but we found this approach performed
worse then not only our best
collaborative filtering algorithm but
just a simple best seller a ranked list
then we used a common artificial neural
network called the sparse auto encoder
but it was still not as effective as
collaborative filtering or the
bestseller list in fact we tried methods
based on singular value decomposition by
linear regression and restricted
Boltzmann machines nope none of these
matrix space matrix completion based
methods underperformed or / performed
compared to our production algorithms
and simple lists we were surprised that
the state-of-the-art methods would
perform worse than a simple bestseller
list so it prompted us to take a step
back and think about the objective
function that we were trying to solve we
looked inside the black box to identify
what was half
I'm gonna explain this in the context of
Prime video but the same approach
applies to many products on Amazon
we found that matrix completion methods
learned that classic or oscar-winning
movies would be of interest to many
customers makes sense however we saw
that given an evening at home on a rainy
Saturday customers prefer to watch a
newly released movie rather than an old
movie in other words Captain Marvel
beats Casablanca this learning became
the foundation of our winning approach
we developed a new model for
recommendations using multi-layer neural
networks for classification with trained
the model using a loss function for
predicting what customers wanted to
watch in the next week what you see on
the screen is the formulation behind the
model we took historical movies that
custom that customers were watching in
order to predict the movie a customer
wanted to watch next week the neural
network classifier outperformed other
neural network based approaches that are
much more complicated the simplicity of
this model made it inherently more
scalable so we could expand to many
millions of products and hundreds of
categories across Amazon and it
performed two times better than
collaborative filtering so we had a
winner after we developed machine
learning technologies across Amazon
we didn't sequester our scientists in
their own group separate from the
business instead we embedded them in the
business teams we integrated scientists
with the folks who are building our
products and like all of our businesses
these teams start with customers an idea
for a better customer experience or a
customer focused product and work
backward they start with a customer
experience that we'd love to deliver at
launch not the machine learning
algorithm and then evolve the approach
over time our machine learning
scientists invent for customers first
but they do get the chance to publish
academic papers along the way and one of
the best parts about my job is that I
get to read the abstract of every
scientific paper that that we published
two years ago I learned about the work
our team was doing with generative
adversarial networked scans to
allow reconstruction of fashion images
in varying styles you'll see a really
cool real-world application of this
technology in a few minutes for the rest
of the hour will focus on three specific
areas where we're deploying AI and
machine learning these these areas are
all about the customer experience in
shopping delivery and voice so let's
stay in the shopping world for a bit
people do not shop the way they did back
in 1995 when Amazon started they don't
shop the way they did in 2015 we started
as a bookstore we're now a collection of
Amazon stores including amazon.com
Amazon go Whole Foods and more and we
make it easy for customers to buy just
about anything they want from virtually
anywhere and have it delivered wherever
and whenever they want it think about
this challenge when shopping for clothes
customers are often inspired by the
fashion looks they see in photos but
they struggle to find Styles they can't
describe in words this past April we
launched style snap which is a new
feature for our iOS mobile app users
this feature lets customers shop for
apparel simply by taking a screenshot of
a look they like customers can take
inspiration from magazines websites
social media influencers and then match
the looks that they love with items that
are available for sale on Amazon store
style snap uses computer vision and
manifold learning to identify an apparel
item and recommend similar items
when a customer uploads an image we use
deep learning for object detection to
identify the various apparel items in
the image and a categorize them into
classes like fit-and-flare dresses or
flannel shirts for me we then find the
most similar items visually similar
items that are available on Amazon we
use a deep embedding model to determine
visual similarity we've trained this
model to ignore the differences between
catalog quality images and lifestyle
images and instead focus on the unique
color style and pattern elements the
customers are looking for style snaps
deep learning approach learns to capture
subtle style attributes like the shape
of the neckline or the size and pattern
of polka dots on a dress that would be
really difficult to describe with words
style snaps a great example of how we're
making shopping even more intuitive the
simple customer experience that results
belies the complexity of the technology
underneath so I've described how Amazon
has used machine learning over the years
and then shown you some of the things
that we're doing to make the customer
experience in Amazon stores even better
now I'd like to introduce Dilip Kumar
who will take you on a first ever public
look behind the technology and invention
that powers Amazon go
[Music]